on passe à présent au titre du jour les
sujets que nous allons aborder
aujourd'hui 16 octobre dans le 78 des
salariés de la succursale yvelinoise de
la Banque de France mobilisée contre
l'annonce de la fermeture de leur agence
ils ont manifesté ce mardi Martin à
Versailles vous les entendrez dans
quelques instants le Press Université
Paris Grand Ouest prend forme un
séminaire inaugural vient de se tenir et
des projets concrets se mettent en place
et comme un institut d'études politiqu
ce serait le 10e en France plus de
détails tout à l'heure actuellement se
tient une opération de sensibilisation
au dépistage du cancer du sein et dans
les ivelines seulement 41 % des femmes
acceptent de pratiquer ce dépistage
pourtant gratuit retour sur l'une des
animations proposées baptisé parapluie
rose c'était à trappe enfin dans le
cadre de la Fête de la Science
chercheurs et passionnés sont partis à
la rencontre du public d'un centre
commercial vous en verrez les images et
la teneur des échanges d'ici la fin de
cette édition et les 18h passéz de
quelques minutes si vous nous suivez en
direct et dans un instant il sera
question de la réforme de l'éducation
vue par les représentants des parents
d'élèves je recevrai aussi ce soir le
secrétaire général du Secours populaire
des ivelines pour l'opération airfood
qui doit permettre d'alerter autour de
la suppression du plan d'aide
alimentaire européen auparavant nous
partons pour Versailles pour le fait du
jour dalariés de la succursale
ivelinoise de la Banque de France étit
mobilisé contre l'annonce de la
fermeture de leur agence ils ont
manifesté ce mardi matin à Versailles
nous retrouvons sur place Anthony Resche
et bris
avril après Montel jolie Saint-Germain
en la c'est auutour de Versailles d'être
victime du plan de restructuration de la
Banque de France la succursale devrait
disparaître d'ici à 2016 un plan qui est
sorti sans négociation sans sans
discussion avec les organisations
syndicales et qui est très violent qui
entraînerait la fermeture d'énormément
de succursales monsieur noyer dans son
communiqué dit que ces succursales ne
fermeraient pas des succursales comme
Versailles qui ont actuellement une
soixantaine d'employés se retrouveraient
à devenir des coquilles vides entre 4 et
10 agents ces quelques agents
continueraient à travailler sur les 4000
dossiers de surendettement traités
annuellement autre fait surprenant pour
Karine Martin c'est la seule succursal
de grande couronnes en Île-de-France qui
fermerait ses portes nous on fait partie
justement des choses assez
incompréhensibles sachant que la barre
était fixé au hauteur de 3000
entreprises côté et que nous on en côte
systématiquement plus de 4000 ne
comprend pas pourquoi Versailles est
visé par cette mesure on peut pas
comprendre c'est c'est vraiment
inexplicable l'autre impact se
ressentirait sur les services
d'entreprise la Banque de France note la
cotation des entreprises en clair elle
confirme leur solvabilité aux banques en
cas de prêt sans ce contrôle la
viabilité des banques françaises serait
en danger la direction versaillaise a
refusé de répondre à nos questions les
employés de la succursale ivelinoise
doivent se positionner sur des
possibilités de reclassement entre 2013
et 2 15 avant la fermeture prévue pour